if the council is blocked on
fundamental issues and the commission is finally weakened,
the union suffers, that is why
we must correct as soon as possible a fundamental
problem such as respect for the
rule of law, because if not, we will not be
able to move forward, my group has
been asking for a mechanism for a long time  of respect for
the rule of law linked to the
budget we finally have
a proposal on the table but it is still
insufficient the rule of law goes
much further it is a
common constitutional heritage that is required of
those who aspire to join the
European Union and is presupposed  To those of
us who are already members, article 2 of the treaty says so,
the union is based on the
values of respect for human dignity, freed
m, democracy, equality, rule of law a
d respect for human rights, plura
ism, non-discri
mination, tolerance, justice, solid
rity and  equality between
men and women this is the heart of
the European project let's not forget it much
more  important
market let's do things right and
avoid falling into blackmail and
haggling europe does not deserve it
someone should be interested in talking about a
supposed conflict between democratic quality
and economic recovery
I want both because I
ask them for responsibility  and let's not
feed divisions democracy is
conquered every day it can never be taken
for granted and that is why it is also
important that this message reaches
citizens that the objective is to help and
that is why we have insisted so much that the
final recipients of the funds do not
are harmed i have heard in
this chamber use
twisted arguments to say that we are
against hungary and poland nothing could be
further from the truth what we want is to
defend the men and women of the
european union regardless of where they
live or what they believe  from now on amen
because that is the rule of law
let's not throw it overboard now
our principles are co
backbone of the union and the budget
is the muscle we need to move
and to move forward let's not give up on any
of them thank you very much
[Applause]